the worst drug disaster in history would
spread through more than 46 countries
and produce up to 20 000 badly deformed
babies worldwide
[Music]
but historians today single out one
birth in 1961 that change the course of
history in Hamburg Germany Linda Schulte
Hillen aged 23 gave birth to her first
child
her husband wasn't with her at the time
and it was quiet there
and then I lay back and was relaxed and
some I mean somebody whispered into my
ear
is your husband not all right
and I was here wide awake and I said
what what's got what has happened to my
baby is anything wrong
yeah she said just
let's say
um without any emotion
um yeah he's just got short arms and I
like a child would have asked possibly I
said and aren't they growing anymore and
she said this can't grow this will be
like it is now
and then I felt like I was beaten to
death
a doctor gave the first time mothers
some friendly advice just get another
child
forget about him you know
throw him away forget about him shortly
afterwards Linda's husband arrived and
gave her some bad news he'd been keeping
from her six weeks earlier his sister
had given birth to a baby with similar
deformities it looks alike like our
child there must be something that is
the same origin the same difficulty the
same problem in the background and we'll
find it and we'll search and we won't
stop until we've found
[Music]
the epidemic of deformed babies began
five and a half years earlier on
Christmas Day 1956 with the birth of the
first victim
[Music]
in the small town of aachen Germany a
mother had taken a new drug called
thalidomite being developed by a local
drug company kamigrunantha her husband
like other grundenthal employees had
taken home a sample which he gave to his
pregnant wife the baby would be the
first of six other than my babies
possibly more born to grinenthal workers
in the years ahead but the company
ignored the early warning signals in
their midst none of that Spirit
grenade's Health when he action grantal
didn't investigate didn't talk to the
mum didn't go to the hospital didn't
look the medical records didn't contact
experts there were multiple
opportunities for granita to cut the
whole disaster short none of them were
taken
nine months after the first deformed
baby was born grunenthal launched the
lineabide onto the German Market under
the brand name contagon
grindenthal's aggressive sales force
whose motto was succeed at any cost
continued to promote the drug contagon
they claimed was a safe sedative
especially for pregnant women suffering
from morning sickness
sales zoomed and thalidomide became the
second best-selling drug next to aspirin
but Linda Schulte Hillen and her husband
Carl Hammond were determined to find out
what caused their son's short arms
months later they were no closer to
finding an answer I know my husband had
times when he said
we won't make it
I think we've
said on
giving up
her husband soon contacted a professor
of obstetrics Dr vidukindlens Who had
received a few reports of deformed
babies my father and Professor Lance
they traveled Germany in their old
Volkswagen and they went from one small
village to another and asked are there
any children with short legs or short
arms born and those kids were hidden
away at that time in the small villages
and he asked in restaurants and bars and
at the local police office and everybody
said no not in our town and then he
showed a picture of me and said this is
my boy and can I please repeat my
question and then they said well at the
end of the road there has been a very
sad incident and then he went there and
drink the dawn showed the first thing he
did was showing the picture of me and
said this is my son do you also have a
kid like this and the people burst in
tears and and children telling my
children were
were pulled to the day of flight
literally
[Music]
in England thalidomide was being sold
under the brand name distaval by the
country's largest liquor manufacturer
the distillers company
as in Germany distillers had received
reports of deformed babies bot had been
assured by grenenthal that the drug was
completely safe
Louise Mason was one of 530 thalidomide
babies born in England over a six and a
half year period Louise only learned
about the circumstances of her birth by
reading her father's best-selling
autobiography I hadn't got any arms and
I hadn't got any legs and my dad said
um it was like little flower buds
um you know from my arms and from my
legs my dad had a look at me
and um
he said my God you're not going to let
this baby live
and they said yes my mum was only 21 and
she was advised by doctors to
um put me away
and
um concentrate on having another family
after 11 days in hospital her parents
took Louise to an institution for
handicapped children where she would
spend the next 18 years of her life
but Louise was fortunate her father had
not asked another doctor to end her life
it is unquestionable
that midwives and doctors
were killing disabled children
in the hospitals in the delivery rooms
on a large scale
in Britain
in Germany
and if they're probably everywhere else
in liege Belgium the mother of an
armless baby decided her daughter's
future was hopeless this was the final
day of the thalidomide trial the baby's
mother and four accomplices were charged
with the murder of the child born
without arms
at last a jury retired to consider their
birdie
guilty all five all five acquitted what
relief and one and watching they got
in Canada another armless baby was
spared by a poor Ukrainian family in
rural Saskatchewan
years later Alvin law learned how
horrified his natural parents were when
he was born ultimately it was the
paternal grandmother who didn't want to
have anything to do with this she said
you're not going to bring that devil
baby home with you he's he's deformed
because of a curse
the armless baby wasn't taken home after
doctors warned he would never lead a
normal life but after six weeks an
elderly couple Jack and Hilda law who
had already raised their own children
volunteered as foster parents and got
their first look at Alvin I took one
look and I thought no wonder nobody
wanted that
and the next time I went to see him of
course they had him bath and dressed and
he didn't look too bad at all
well I wasn't in favor of taking him
talk no way we'd raised our family and
that was it but
it was a baby with nobody wanted him so
what are you gonna do
turned out okay
my life story
shifted the moment that Sophie and Peter
my birth father gave me up
that that is a profound chapter shift in
my life
because I went to live with the laws
my life became this life
[Music]
[Applause]
in Cincinnati Ohio a deeply religious
Roman Catholic couple with six children
were expecting another normal birth my
mother's story is that when I was born
they were not at all prepared
the doctor said Joy your baby doesn't
have any legs
so she says that she took the baby me
and she said well Eileen is my four-leaf
clover
I have a sibling who told me that my
father cried and that when he came home
he handed me to my siblings and everyone
got very upset
and they said take it away
um
someone ripped off the blankets and said
that's not a baby or something to that
effect that's not our sister
um
that was what I was told
as a young child
um
painful
Eileen Cronin was one of several
thalidomide babies born in Cincinnati
where an American Drug Company
Richardson Merrell had their
headquarters like the German Drug
Company Meryl promoted the drug as
completely safe even during pregnancy
like grindenthal Merrill had no evidence
to back this up
Merrell applied to the Federal Drug
Administration in 1960 for approval to
bring thalidomide onto the American
market and was allowed to conduct
clinical trials on patients across the
country now it wasn't a clinical trial
at all what it was was a marketing
campaign trumped up to look like a
clinical trial
Michael magazanic is an Australian
lawyer and former investigative reporter
who spent years researching the
thalidomide disaster
what Merrell wanted to do was to
familiarize doctors with their drug so
that once they got approval they would
have doctors all ready to go thrilled
with the drug ready to prescribe it like
crazy
during this time Richards and Merrill
handed out two and a half million
solidified pills to thousands of doctors
in the United States and Canada in
Winnipeg Dr Claude Murphy was one of
those doctors we received it in
quantities like a thousand pills a
doctor was given free to pass out to his
patients to a tremendous pressure on all
over the world to get this wonderful new
drug on the market and the companies
that were producing it
even after there were came questions
about its safety kept right on pushing
it
Dr Murphy had good reason to be
concerned about the emerging thalidomide
disaster as he awaited the birth of his
fourth child his wife Peggy had been
prescribed thalidomide by another doctor
I'd warned the nurses at the hospital we
could be in for trouble and we willed
into the delivery room and went into the
doctor's addressing them and I turned
looked through the window and I saw the
nurse looking with horror at the at the
stretcher you know and realized there
was something wrong so I burst into the
room and he'd come breach you see
because of his lack of legs of a small
bum and his large head there he was
stuck with the on the stretcher with the
uh just as bottom so the nurse got me a
pair of forceps and I slipped the
forceps over his after coming ahead and
delivered him and I
if I hadn't been there You Never Would
Have Made It
so as soon as he was born he started
screaming
no hesitation at all he's there
never stop screaming suits
thanks
I'd have to say I was pretty devastated
by the whole thing I'd never dealt with
anybody who had like physical
deficiencies before and then I had to
to break the news to the other kids and
did that the next day or so
it was uh
surprising
well they said
um Dad you got to bring that baby home
[Music]
pallidomide was now being sold in close
to 50 countries worldwide in 1961 in
Australia Dr William McBride delivered
three thalidomide babies in a few months
he alerted distillers the British
distributor of thalidamite but they
claimed they never received his warnings
and pregnant mothers like Wendy Rowe
continued to take thalidomide for
morning sickness
but when her daughter Lynette was born
Wendy immediately knew something was
wrong when she was born there was just
deadly silence in the in the room and I
just knew that something must be wrong
and nobody said a word it was just
loud silence
and um anyway finally they said to me
that there was a problem and that Lynn
had no arms and legs and
um you know and they gave it to me and
she she doesn't look very different to
what she does now she had sticky up hair
in the cutest little face
and um
but I yeah it's just like well it was
like a nightmare I suppose you know but
then I you know when you you looked at
her and thought would you you've got to
love it you can't you know you can't do
anything about it but they said we think
she's got some brain damage but we don't
know what extent and I just looked at it
and I thought here's this little thing
no arms and legs and if she's got brain
damage as well what hopefully she got
they told me that I should put her in a
home that she would be dead in six
months
we left her there for a week while we
went away
just to get our head around it all and
then came back to pick her up and that
was really hard going back to the
hospital to pick her up
[Music]
in Germany grunenthal's advertising
campaign was paying huge dividends the
company's owner and Executives were
making fortunes overnight especially
Heinrich mukter grenenthal's research
director
during the war mukhtar served as a Nazi
doctor developing vaccines which were
tested on Jewish prisoners in the
bookenval concentration camp many of
whom died
after the war mukter joined grunenthal
nine years later he invented thalidomide
and received a bonus for every
thalidomide pill sold worldwide the drug
was such a success for grunenthal
that they started making money hand over
fist and Heinrich mukter who was on a
percentage of profits
move from being modestly affluent to
having so much money pouring in he could
have bought himself a new Mercedes every
month by 1961 really he's making 20
times his salary in
turnover percentage so he's getting this
massive massive bonus he's become a
ludicrously rich man on the back of
thalidomide
what would a man like that with a
history of wartime experimentation
strong personality a massive income
riding on the sales of vlitimide what
would one expect that he would do when
confronted with reports of nerve damage
and other side effects I mean it is not
surprising to me that there was not a
rush at grunental to investigate to get
to the bottom of it to put warnings on
the truck to withdraw to take all sorts
of precautions they did none of that
they just focused on selling more of the
drug
in Germany where the pills sold at a
rate of 15 million a month five thousand
children have been born deformed from
stolberg Germany Morley Safer reports in
November of 1961 just 300 miles from
here in Hamburg Dr vitican Lentz the
director of human genetics at the
University of Hamburg found an
astounding increase in the number of
deformed babies he deduced that contagan
or thalidomide was the cause
was clearly going to take something or
someone extraordinary to force
grudential to withdraw the drug and that
didn't happen until lands contacted them
he spoke to Heinrich mukta and said I
have these very strong suspicions I have
14 cases of birth malformations where I
think it could only be thalidomide I
think you ought to withdraw the drug
mocta wouldn't withdraw it instead
grunenthal's response to lens was to
send out reassuring letters to German
doctors grinental sent out 66 000
letters to German doctors declaring
their drug was safe
66 000 letters to German doctors I mean
you know it's
that was a period where they'd been told
that their drug was likely responsible
for an epidemic of malformations and
deaths
and they're telling doctors their drug
is safe and it really wasn't until the
Press got hold of it
and they knew it was going to go public
that they finally backed off and agreed
on November 28 1961 a day after the
thalidomide Scandal made headlines in
West Germany grundenthal announced it
was withdrawing the drug from the market
even if as late as the spring of 1961
they had taken the drug off the market
then they would have spared half the
babies
Nico Von glazo's disabilities weren't so
severe but as a young child Nico had
trouble adjusting to his short arms
as it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
in England Louise Mason didn't see her
parents and three siblings for months at
a time
I was left alone most the time my
parents had other children there's no
way that they could leave them with my
nan
because my grandpa was ill
so they just stopped coming
I went home three weeks a year
for a week one week in the summer one
week Christmas on my week at Easter
every holiday was like getting to know
your brothers and sisters again
we had a lot of fun when I was a kid we
had a lot of fun I had a very good
childhood
I mean clearly when God made me he
didn't have somebody making handstands
on his mind so the handicap came
annoying from time to time even as a
child he was completely free he was
completely Fearless
for him it was natural I don't see
myself as as disabled
um let's put it this way I have short
arms and this can come very annoying
from time to time but I'm not disabled
too that I feel inferior that I think I
cannot do certain things
in Yorkton Saskatchewan Alvin Law's
parents decided the best way to get
their armless son to cope with life was
to turn his toes into fingers for hours
Alvin was given manual tasks to perform
with his feet
now granted having no arms isn't exactly
a
simple disability it's a very
complicated disability
and I'd be lying if I didn't say it was
a lot of work a lot of work a lot of
times spent by myself being very lonely
being very afraid and very frustrated
but I think it was the character that
was built by my parents especially by my
parents
that allowed me to not really think that
I was all that different
it's not an easy thing to get dressed
but
again it goes back to the basic theory
of my life and that is do I have someone
look after me or do I look after myself
[Music]
but more than anything I think it's a
mindset you know that okay there's a lot
of people in our world that have way
bigger problems than I have so that I
have to spend a little extra effort
putting my clothes on
so what
the moment I started using my toes and
my feet and my legs
was the same moment I ceased to have a
disability
in the United States there would have
been thousands of thalidomide babies
like Alvin law except for the actions of
one woman Dr Francis Kelsey a
canadian-born doctor and pharmacologist
had just joined the Federal Drug
Administration when she received an
application to bring thalidomide onto
the American Market here was a drug that
looked like it should be no problem but
at the same time there was just a
feeling that
there was something in the data or the
absence of data that
was a cause of concern the application
came from Richardson Merrill one of
America's oldest drug companies known
years ago for its best-selling product
Vic's cough drops I mean Kelsey was
extraordinarily determined Brave tough
resilient I mean she kept knocking back
Merrill's application she kept telling
them that there was not the testing to
back their application that it was
substandard they never managed to
persuade her their drug was safe and fit
for sale Merrill poured on the pressure
they contacted the FDA 50 times they
went behind her back to her superiors
they complained about her in writing
they threatened libel proceedings they
pushed and pushed and pushed and she was
Resolute she was unbelievably tough
when I know that we're all as most
indebted to Dr Kelsey the relationship
the hopes that all of us have for our
children in August 1962 President John F
Kennedy awarded the highest civilian
honor an American can receive to Dr
Francis Kelsey so Kelsey really saved
the United States from a german-style
furthermite epidemic then Meryl was
ready to go Merrill had tons of the drug
in the United States it had already
spread two and a half million pills
around around the country to doctors
it had a sales force schooled in the
multiple wonders of Florida Mart and all
the fake inflated claims for its
usefulness and its safety and if Kelsey
had given them the green light the
United States would have been flooded
with a drug and there would have been a
birth malformation epidemic in that
country to rival that in Germany while
Dr Kelsey said I need to know more I
want to have more I demand to have more
the Canadian government simply approved
it and I believe that was below the
standard of what should have been
expected from an industrialized
first world
country like very civilized Canada
thalidomide continued to be sold in
Canada for four months after it was
withdrawn from the German Market the
Food and Drug directorate in Ottawa
issued no warnings to the public while
the drug remained on Pharmacy shelves
the Canadian government and its Food and
Drug directorate could have done
something four months earlier and
they're about 30 Canadians whose mothers
took the drug
after the whistle had been blown in
Germany and after the Canadian drug
companies knew that the drug was
dangerous but kept selling it
I come home from the playground one day
my mom says honey good news you're going
to get arms dear I mean you just
remember a day like that right I thought
we were going shopping you know arms are
us I don't know
but I was very confused they had Hooks
and they were made of metal and plastic
and wood I mean and I couldn't take off
my shoes I wasn't allowed to use my feet
can you imagine how weird that was
so this became an interesting life half
of my life was being Alvin law the kid
with no arms the other half of my life
was this terrible victim of thalidomide
I lost my sense of who I was right stick
these arms on me I'm not out of the law
anymore
Alvin lawn doesn't have any arms
artificial or not
and why why would I need them
I mean there was no good reason not One
Good Reason
to use them for years I told them hey
these aren't doing me any good
and it was like shut up
that was how blunt it was you know we
know what we're doing you don't
[Music]
most of the dividers don't use
artificial limbs today but Eileen Cronin
is an exception she wears artificial
legs every day to get around
I was born with both legs missing from
the knees down
according to my mother I did adapt to
the legs pretty quickly
if you have
you know artificial legs a lot of things
go wrong you've got to go around
conducting your life and yet you know
you've got a skin infection and you've
got to put your leg on what are you
going to do
me I put the leg on I go that's not
always the best thing to do
but um
that's what I do
in Australia artificial limbs prove to
be useless and even dangerous for
Lynette Rowe these legs would design for
leading to walking but they're terribly
dangerous because every step she took
she had to rock from side to side the
least little thing on the path she would
just fall over straight down
Lynette required the full-time care of
her devoted parents
for years her mother's nightly routine
was always the same
and you know getting up in the night and
turning her and giving her a pain and
it's just sort of it's a constant thing
that um
I talked to some young mothers sometimes
and they say oh I've had to get up the
night I said I've been doing that for 52
years
the rows are an extraordinary family and
when I went out there for the first time
to meet
um
to meet the family
I found it profoundly moving I mean they
were you know Lynn was 47 or 48 years
old by that time her parents had cared
for her as her primary carers for that
entire period
when is catastrophically injured
and she has a remarkable Spirit but
she's catastrophically physically
injured and their parents it's defined
her parents lives
if he has enough thank you you sure
okay
[Music]
in March 1967 the owner and eight
Executives of grunenthal the German Drug
Company were charged with criminal
negligence premeditated bodily harm and
manslaughter
among the defendants was Heinrich mukter
the Nazi Doctor Who made a fortune
inventing thalidomide one German
historian has looked
at a short list of grunenthal staff from
the early 60s and he said it's
absolutely astonishing that a small
company should have such a concentration
of convicted war criminals on its staff
unusual even by the standards of
post-war Germany
another chop gronenthal executive was
Otto Ambrose a Nazi war criminal known
as the devil's chemist Ambrose was
convicted of war crimes he committed at
Auschwitz for which he served four years
in prison but after the war the chemist
found no shortage of employers including
Dow Chemical JP to Grace and the U.S
Army's chemical Corps before he became
chairman of grunenthal's board of
directors in 1971. so in the 1970s
granitol head as the chair of its board
a Man convicted of mass murder and
slavery at Auschwitz it sounds crazy
when you say it out loud I mean a mass
murderer as the chair of their board
[Applause]
hired Nazi war criminals like Ambrose
and mukter was grindenthal owner Hermann
wurtz
verts was a member of the local Nazi
party in his hometown before the second
world war a service for which he was
handsomely rewarded by Adolf Hitler the
Viet family companies
had actually thrived during the War
years because they'd had a contract from
the German Army to supply soap and
detergents
they had been supplied with slave
workers
they had been basically handed two
companies on a plate that were both
either jewish-owned or Jewish controlled
Joseph neuberger was the personal lawyer
for grunenthal's owner Herman verts but
in December 1966 neuberger resigned
suddenly and became Justice minister in
the province where the trial was being
held Granite house chief defense lawyer
ended up with a government
responsibility for overseeing the
conduct of the trial
that kind of stinks
and one German Observer of the day said
this makes us look worse than a Banana
Republic
away from The Trial a secret deal was
worked out between grenenthal's owner
hairman verts and the provincial
government the secret deal was only
revealed when the trial was dramatically
stopped after two and a half years under
the deal volumes of the prosecution's
evidence would be sealed from public
View
in return for having all the serious
criminal charges against its owner and
Executives dropped the company agreed to
pay the victims lifetime pensions
ranging from 30 to 140 dollars a month
as well as small one-time payments but
in order to collect the money
thalidomide has had to agree not to
launch any further suits against
grenenthal so taken as a whole the trial
was a glorious if unlocked the Triumph
the green and tile greninjao really
escaped from the disaster relatively
lightly given the scale and the scope of
the tragedy
[Music]
while Canada loudly celebrated its 100th
birthday in 1967. the thalidomide
families suffered in silence a few
parents had committed suicide others
became alcoholics and some were having
severe psychiatric problems
[Music]
the children were now school age but the
question that plagued medical and
educational authorities was what type of
school should they enter some experts
recommended schools for the handicapped
While others advised the regular
education system
in Yorkton Saskatchewan Alvin Law's
parents had run into opposition from the
local grade school when they tried to
enroll him School says wait he's got no
arms he can't go to this school we don't
have such a thing as integration mom and
dad are going what's integration he's a
kid he needs to go to school he needs to
learn he needs to be educated he can
write he can read what else do you need
the school finally agreed to take Alvin
but soon afterwards he ran into a
reaction his teachers expected and
feared I came home and I was very upset
because somebody had called me crippled
and I'd never heard that word before it
was never used in this house
it was never used in this neighborhood
but I go to school and there was new
kids and someone called me crippled so I
had to run home and I was a little
freaked out you know Mom calmed me down
and that's when I first remember hearing
those words that some people are born
with black hair and some people are born
with blonde hair and you were born
without arms
compared to Alvin Mony eisenberg's
disabilities were relatively small she
was born with a short arm but
nevertheless her mother was determined
to hide it from public view when she was
a child
only years later did Moni understand why
um
I's mother couldn't forget that the
first victims Adolf Hitler and the Nazis
rounded up for extermination were
disabled children she had lived near
hadamar Hospital one of the
extermination sites foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
there was the hospitals where they were
taking these disabled people to to be
murdered that were really the test beds
for the Holocaust it was it was in a
hospital that the first gas Chambers
were being used for bulk killing of
people
born
um
foreign
the medical staff of these places were
very enthusiastic supporters and I seen
a report from hadimar hospital where the
the chief of this program organized a
party for all the staff when they had
killed their ten thousandth victim
in England 197 families of thalidomide
children were suing distillers the
British company which had distributed
the drug distillers made a ridiculously
low offer of compensation and warned
that the money would be paid out only if
all parents agree to the lifetime deal
five families refused the offer they
were led by David Mason a wealthy London
art dealer and father of Louise now I
came under tremendous pressure I
received threats on my life I had a
police guard for a period of time I had
Anonymous phone calls I had Anonymous
letters I had you know threats from
parents her father's well-publicized
opposition to the compensation created
problems for Louise at her care
institution up until then I was sort of
like one of the crowd but after that
I was picked on
and that's when I felt like
I was
alone in amongst a crowd
Louise escaped the hostility of her
classmates when her father took her out
to participate in publicity events for
his campaign I was used as a as a poster
girl
not only because I was his daughter but
because I had the extremes of the
disability
and Visually I had great impact
David Mason's campaign succeeded in
increasing by six times the drug
company's original offer to the parents
I did pay a heavy price personally
but
if I hadn't paid that price
the filler dividers wouldn't have got
the compensation when they got the
compensation
so I think it was worth it
the little Motors were becoming
teenagers and in Winnipeg Paul Murphy
was having a difficult adolescence he
went to high school with other kids and
of course he did have problems because
he was rejected he did make a few
friends but
uh not very many
I think everybody's running into those
kind of problems but or just being told
no I don't want to
go with you because of your situation
not fun not a nice thing to have happen
nobody likes to have that kind of
rejection thrown at them
but there's some very frustrating times
and and whoever says they've never felt
almost self-destructive and not want you
know Jesus would be a hell of a lot
easier if I wasn't
I've been to those low points luckily
enough I was able to pull myself back
out
[Music]
Alvin law thrived in school and by the
time he was a teenager he seemed to fit
right in
as far as the whole scene of school has
been I think that's the most important
part is being accepted by people if
you're not accepted um it won't be worth
anything it was about acceptance totally
and it was about asking two or three
girls out on dates to which I heard are
you kidding
I wanted to date just like any 16 year
old
but I didn't have that good fortune and
of course I used to blame it on the
girls and maybe it was partly them but I
know it was mostly me I thought that I
was gonna have to be a nun
I didn't think that I was gonna go on
dates I didn't know what was going to
happen and that that's not how it
happened I I had a great High School run
I mean you know I had a lot of fun I had
a lot of friends I had too much fun
if you're like me and my friends you
drive around and you look for pools and
you go skinny dipping and that's what we
did for entertainment I never had a
problem with girls
I could always get very nice girls
beautiful girls intelligent girls
but I couldn't get the
Blonde one
and I wanted the stupid Blonde one for a
one night stand
but that I never achieved she was
wearing glasses and I didn't notice
[Laughter]
I found my
now wife when she was 16.
and um
maybe you call it a lack of opportunity
but I'm still with her
she was blonde and not stupid
for most politomizers getting behind the
wheel of a car was the road to
Independence and freedom
Louise Mason was determined to drive no
matter how difficult it was for her just
physically to get behind the wheel and
do a percepa
oh
[Applause]
foreign
person let alone somebody had gotten
arms and legs but the tests we took
was exactly the same as everyone else
there's no difference
it came so natural because I've been
driving electric wheelchairs for
you know most of my life
um
getting in a car was just a bigger
wheelchair really
my parents they were the most practical
people I think I've ever met in my
entire life so when it came to learning
how to drive
that was just practical that way you can
get around on your own you don't depend
on people to take care of you you don't
have to worry about you know taking a
bus or using a cab and it was really
just about trying to figure it out
I just love driving
my favorite things in the world to do
most people don't consider the power of
my mind
and I my mind is a very powerful tool
and it it interjects all kinds of things
into my system so that my feet are
literally
my hands so when it comes to driving
I take it really seriously and I have
high expert why can't I can drive with
one foot on the wheel what is people's
excuse they've got both hands and their
feet and yet they drive like [ __ ]
this doesn't make any sense to me
in Germany Nico Von glazo knew from an
early age he had to choose a future
occupation that would not require the
use of his deformed arms
I realized quite soon I'm never will be
a conductor or a painter or a dancer
I can't sing so I became a director
because I'm you know I can't do anything
else
to pursue his dream Nico went to
prestigious film schools and apprenticed
under the legendary German director
Raynor Vernon fassbinder before making a
number of successful feature films but
there was one prized job he wanted
better directing a big movie on
thalidomide and the head of German TV
said no you can't have the job but you
can make a documentary on uh uh
thalitamide and I said you know I you
know I that wasn't come and I shouted at
him I I used the f word very loudly and
very often
because I said I apply for the job you
know you pay well and not the F
documentary filmmaker who gets not paid
yeah and that's so typical you know you
give the disabled guy the side job yeah
and then I went home and my wife said
what's the matter and I told her they
want me to do a film about thalidomide
and what do I know about thalidomite
yeah
and she looked at me and said
Nico it's time to look the devil in this
[ __ ]
Moni Eisenberg was being raised by a
poor single mother after her father died
in a mountaineering accident when she
was nine by the time she was a teenager
Monie had become an activist against
grenenthal if kunathar as a company can
act in a way they have in the case of
contagon there are really no boundaries
between right and wrong
[Music]
over the next 40 years money
participated in protests and hunger
strikes against the drug company but
there was also tragedy that occurred
regularly over the years that brought
money to the gates of the grindenthal
plant this is a place where they spread
out all this poison in the world an
effect of so many people and so many
families and it's um let me always a bit
shiver in the inside because it's
touching me too much
foreign
letters and candles here to grunenthal
anytime when I heard that somebody of
our survivors when they died
we need to remember all these people all
these victims of grunenthal and
just to remember that we are still here
what the little matters didn't know was
that the drug was still in circulation
though grunenthal had stopped producing
the drug thalidomide made an early
comeback in the mid 60s when other
suppliers began manufacturing it in
India and some South American countries
where it had become the drug of choice
for treating leprosy by
1972 and 1973 we're now 12 years after
the withdrawal of the drug
it's reported in use at 62 leprosy
centers around the world
and was clearly being used on a massive
scale
one of the main countries using it for
this application had been Brazil and by
2003 there were there were probably in
the order of a thousand thalidomide
babies had been born in Brazil across
that period
and the ability to control this euphoric
addictive drug that's widely available
in Latin America is impossible
so at this point I do want to introduce
my good buddy he's become a good buddy
Timmy come on up Allen Law found himself
in the public Limelight when he became
his province's spokesman for a
handicapped children
[Music]
over the years Alvin would make
appearances on telethons across the
country
[Music]
foreign
people
because I'm not a handicapped person
that's where people get it wrong right
they look at Alvin law and they think
God it's tremendous how he can do things
with his feet
well I suppose if you look at your feet
it's tremendous but these are my feet
these are my hands too and I have been
doing it forever these are not
tremendous feet these are the only thing
that I've got
so when I pick up a cup and I have a
drink you know
wow what a thrill that's not what it is
that's how I do think
[Music]
[Applause]
life wasn't so kind for another
thalidomide poster child Louise Mason
continued to endure bullying from other
kids at her Institution for the handicap
but one day when she was 13 she was
raped by another student
Louise went to a nurse for help
I was shaking I was tearful
and um
and they took my underwear off
and saw blood and I tried to explain to
them what had happened but they did
nothing
they did nothing at all
Louise endured five more years of fear
and loneliness before finally leaving
the institution then like any 18 year
old Louise immediately started to enjoy
the freedom and joys of college life
orange part is just the sheer hell of
going to the prices I'd be absolutely
cream crackers but I'd still go because
it was something that I shouldn't have
done or wasn't allowed to do
I went to the pub regularly
drug not severe regularly I got into
trouble there you weren't supposed to
have boys in your room when I did
and but I made it say I got to the vice
president of the Student Union
and got well respected
unlike Louise Mason who rarely saw her
mother during childhood Jan shelter
Hillen formed a close bond with his
mother from birth and her unwavering
support and encouragement were critical
in his career decision she never lost
hope she she said you everything you
want to achieve in your life you're
going to achieve it I have absolutely no
doubt
and when I when I turned up with the
with the idea that
um that I wanted to be a doctor
everybody told me you should not it's
not a very good idea you cannot do that
you will have severe problems she said
Son Do Your Own Thing if that's what you
want to do you're gonna manage
Yan is now an emergency room doctor in
Switzerland I don't consider my
condition as a major issue I mean I'm
not a thalidomide in first part I'm
first but I'm a man I'm trying to be a
good doctor I'm trying to be a good
husband I'm the father and a lover
and I have short arms
and that's it and and if people have
problems
um accepting me or
I have problems to interact with me
because I have short arms it's their
problem it's not mine
in Canada most of the countries
thalidomiders hadn't received a penny of
compensation for their injuries for 25
years the Canadian government had failed
to live up to its promises to look after
the victims of this drug so the war
amputees of Canada brought them to
Ottawa in 1987.
unlike their German and English
counterparts the Canadian victims had
spent 25 years separate and apart from
each other it's kind of interesting
finally after 25 years to sit down with
a group of people you're kind of related
to and start to find out exactly what
everybody else is doing
the thalidomide victims Association of
Canada was formed with Paul Murphy being
elected vice president and Alvin law
recording secretary
after years of waiting suffering and
fighting for compensation Canadian
victims of thalidomide are finally
getting the help they need from the
federal government yesterday the health
Minister said survivors of the drug will
receive lifelong pensions individuals
can now start feeling comfortable about
their future they know they have a a an
amount of money coming in every year
that can support them and help them hey
I don't know what your lives are like
sometimes life can really be rough on
people I understand that I get it I've
been in real life
Alvin law is a motivational speaker
whose influenced audiences in North
America and Australia with his message
of Hope especially to more than 2
million youngsters who've heard his talk
speaking is the best thing that I could
have ever decided to do you're helping
kids and they need to have somebody come
in and tell them that it's going to be
okay
but I get such tremendous joy out of
doing it there is nothing in my life
that makes me happier than speaking to
kids nothing and the next time you're
ready to give up or quit or pack it in
well if it helps even a little bit
remember the goofy looking guy that
played the drums with his feet
but remember the words I live by every
day
there's no such word
as
can't
thanks man we'll see you again
how many people can say that they can go
out and speak to a group for an hour
and have them actually you can see a
change you can see the reflection
see the thought that's going on in their
mind as to what they've just experienced
Alvin travels over a hundred thousand
miles a year on his own but after 30
years on the road his body is starting
to wear out it takes its toll you know
carrying that stuff around I mean you
know my body may not last as long as
normal bodies do because of what I'm
putting it through I mean as much as I
make this look easy
I'm still putting my body through a lot
of stuff just the pain in my back from
carrying my luggage and scar tissue in
my shoulder from carrying a briefcase
for 35 years and you know there's not
really a shoulder here so what I'm
carrying it with I shouldn't be doing
this I should have like a sherpa or
something
hey how does a guy without arm
with straps eye check into hotels all on
my own I I rent cars write my keys there
you go thank you boss right in my toes
thank you all right now why do I rent
cars I it's just how I prefer to
function I don't do cabs because
strangely they don't stop when you go
I'm still tromping around going to
airports checking into hotels eating bad
food driving everywhere in the middle of
nowhere getting involved in blizzards
and swearing at my wife for putting me
out yet in another life and death
situation and not thinking I'm getting
paid enough see what I mean I can get on
a rant but at the end of the day she
also says this line This is a wonderful
line
honey if you're tired of traveling I'm
sure there's a cubicle with your name
written on it in a windowless office
somewhere in the middle of nowhere for a
mundane job that you'd hate in five
minutes
and then it goes away
foreign
[Music]
Nico Von glazo had to overcome his
lifetime aversion to other thalidomiders
when he decided to make a documentary in
which he and 11 other victims would pose
Noob for a calendar first I went to a
disability school and from that moment
on I wanted to have nothing to do with
thalidomiters anymore
and then because I made this film
nobody's perfect I was kind of forced to
meet them again and I hated to make this
film
why
I didn't want to look at myself
[Music]
nobody's perfect changed everything
it changed how I look at myself
it changed the movement of the dividers
completely because the first time not
lawyers not someone else not doctors who
are fighting for us
really big time we were fighting
I think for me for us as Toledo miners
but also for the public
something changed
the energy changed
Nico van glazo Palladio
Nobody's Perfect
[Music]
in 2008 Nico received the German
equivalent of an Oscar for his
documentary on thalidoma
deutschlands
media
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
College Eileen Cronin fell in love with
Andy a graduate student in economics I
was in love very definitely at first
sight
um although
I already had a boyfriend you know I
immediately was drawn to her uh you know
her vivaciousness and intelligence and
um her wit
we moved in together
um
and we got pregnant very quickly
um very quickly
I was racked with worry all my life
about having a child because I didn't
know for sure that my mother had taken
thalidomide
I was kind of panicked
um it started to settle in oh my God I'm
gonna have a baby I don't even know if I
can have a baby
um I don't know if the baby's gonna have
legs or not have legs or something else
but also literally I did not know how I
was gonna carry a baby in my body and so
um they did the ultrasound
the ultrasound technician
zoomed in right away found foot one foot
blew it up took a picture and wrote foot
and then other foot hands fingers and
I was crying and all the interns started
clapping
we knew that she would be okay
[Music]
Anya and Eileen are best friends it's
it's not hard to understand why Anya
took up to be
a ballet dancer because that's something
her mother wanted to be
and she was very young
oh you are so beautiful
[Music]
when his first wife Sandy became
pregnant Alvin law was terrified about
what the future held
when I saw him come out of there with
two arms and
two hands and five little fingers on
each hand
I didn't care what brand he was at all I
don't care if it was a she or he or it
didn't matter
and it was just the most tremendous
feeling it was my son
do it again okay here we go
[Music]
can you throw it back I worried a lot
about how I was gonna play ball with
them and I was gonna maybe how could I
teach them you know how to golf and
teach them to play Frisbee and teach
them to throw you know I mean all those
things that you want to have a kid of
yours do
[Music]
you don't have to have arms to be a
father
you don't need arms to love him
you don't need arms to be there
you don't need arms to listen
you don't need arms to be a father at
all
unfortunately too many fathers that have
arms don't realize that
never forget that and that's true you
just have to be there for him
[Music]
that surprised me
the tears I don't know I'm not sad I'm
just
wow
he's big now
there's little them
yeah well I missed that little boy
sometimes but that's not how life works
right he's a normal regular person he's
uh he's got the same regular personality
there's nothing really wrong about it
and you just have to
just have to know him and you can't just
judge him by the way he looks what he
brings and what he gives is much more so
than anything arms could bring you know
he he gives a great you know fatherly
advice and he's a great role model he's
a great person
and that's all you can ask
my disability is not the most important
thing whatever happened to me
my children are the most important thing
whatever happened to me
something lovely
was the most important in my life not
something you know which went wrong I
don't think I ever actually sort of
consciously realized there wasn't
a moment or
a time where I consciously thought oh my
dad is disabled
um and I never really had any issue with
it for them it was the same like for
KiKi or also for me it you know when
when you are with me longer than you
know a few hours you just forgot there
isn't much you can't do with me so apart
from maybe playing rugby there isn't
much you I can't do with him like I
couldn't couldn't do it otherwise he's a
pretty good father and he's very uh
a big character
to say released
it's good to be rich
yeah I work on it I'm getting rich by
the minute
more and more
why not
it's nice you know just bought myself a
castle
Nico's Castle is a 15th century home in
Tuscany with 108 rooms including 18
bedrooms I'm very good with money I mean
I invested at the right moment into
Apple
and I went out at the right moment
Nico uses a lot of his money to finance
charities in Asia including an orphanage
in the Philippines and a film School in
Tibet
so rich people have the tendency to our
stingy bastards and I don't want to be
one of them
Louise Mason had been a single mother
for 10 years when she received a
Christmas card from an old boyfriend I'd
heard that Louise hadn't been very well
and sent her a Christmas card and come
down and said hello and I think the
spark reignited is the best way to
describe it
a a kiss me goodbye
and butterflies were
I was sort of floating on on a cloud
and he told his wife that he was leaving
she helped him pack the car
and then he moved down here
we've been together since
that was it
political understanding with each other
it's really weird you know Louise can
nod at something and you guys wouldn't
know what I'm talking you know what
she's done about but I know straight
away what she's pointing at you know
just a nod of the head or or a mannerism
you pick up you know the little more did
you just pick up on each other it says
oh we've got a sixth sense you know it's
really really fascinating we communicate
here with each other without even
talking
so we've and I think we I think we were
made for each other to be honest yeah
you know I remember thinking 28 years
old divorced got a kid losing my hair
gaining a gut have no arms what a
package and then I got to thinking you
know I've got to change this
that's how Alvin introduced himself to
his future wife Darlene who was sitting
in the audience one day that conference
was the first time I heard him speak and
it actually believe it or not sounds
corny but it was a life-changing event
for me
I was in the process of um
considering making a final decision
about a rather unhappy marriage
I thought yeah he's right life is too
short I have to make decisions for
myself
I mean anybody that sees her for the
first time can't miss that smile and
just absolutely melt and I melted
friends who tell me that I smiled more
the day of my wedding than they've ever
seen me smile in my entire life and it
was permanently glued there for days
that was the beginning of the joy
that ended in that ring going on that
finger and it's still there today
uh you can't even describe it
it's like all these years of angst and
frustration just melted away in five
minutes
you still love them I do it's kind of
he's kind of gross on you
you know life is never she's past her
best before date so she's got no choice
you've got to stick with me now there's
no option yeah
I don't stop traffic anymore
no you know we've had our ups and our
downs and we've had some
some a lot of
lows just like anybody else but it just
getting better I know it sounds cliche
but it's getting easier and better and
more fun there's a lot of credit that I
get for doing this
but I didn't just do this you know I had
my parents first I had my teachers
second and then I had her
and those three elements of my life have
been get they've really been what has
supplied the fuel for what drives me
[Music]
that's squirrel waving at us
oh
I met Paul on the internet and I got a
message from this gentleman that had a
kind of cute picture so we started
emailing back and forth and uh I came
out to visit and moved I fell in love
quickly
um I never noticed his disability
because it was Paul that I was
interested in the person that he is and
his disability didn't matter to me
I always say he's the least disabled
person I know the words I live by
are
there's always a solution
over under around or through
in 1997 the thalidomide victims
Association of Canada faced an agonizing
Choice a small American Drug Company
Celgene wanted to bring thalidomide onto
the market as a treatment for leprosy
and cancer but needed the approval of
the Federal Drug Administration in
Washington
Celgene sought the support of Canadian
victims for its application
if thalidomide can change for the better
the life of a child with cancer then
let's produce it and let's give it to
these children and let's make their
lives better and if it's because of the
price that we had to pay
good then maybe we can have some solace
in knowing that it wasn't all in vain in
July 1998 the U.S Food and Drug
Administration licensed a
thalidomide-based drug but imposed the
tightest rules on its use for any drug
in history
officially Celgene got FDA approval for
thalidomide to treat lepers a minuscule
American Market but the drug company
quickly began focusing on it as a
treatment from multiple myeloma a cancer
of the blood cells and got approval for
that use in 2006. today Celgene leads
the market for drug treatment of
multiple myeloma in North America and
many European Union countries selling
its patented thalidomide derivative for
approximately ten thousand dollars a
month or 333 dollars uphill
most recently in 2013 a major survey was
done by a team of scientists reviewing
they reviewed over 70 studies
the conclusion was that any benefit from
thalidomide was very marginal and the
risks were very high
in Australia grunenthal and diagio the
British company that bought distillers
were co-defendants in a multi-million
dollar class action suit centered on the
Lynette Road case Melbourne woman
Lynette Rowe is suing the drugs
manufacturer at grunenthal the company
wanted the case heard in Germany where
it's never successfully been sued but
the Victorian supreme court today
dismissed that application this was an
application by the company that made
thalidomide the worst drug in the
history of Medicine
to have an armless legless woman who has
no money and doesn't speak German if she
wishes to have her day in court have to
move to Germany for the next five years
so we had Diageo and grenatal as our
defendants
grin and tell have this never give in
never admit a thing never concede fight
the bit around attitude distillers or
diagio took a much more
compassionate sensible we'd say approach
which was once convinced of the strength
of the claim they settled with Lynn
grudential didn't pay a cent we had to
get up and face each day and every day
and cope with the incredible damage the
gruenthood
to Lynn and our family the settlement
amount was a multi-million dollar sum it
was a sum sufficient to provide Lynn
with first class care for the rest of
her life it really has dramatically
transformed the rose lives grunenthal
refused to pay a cent of the
multi-million dollar settlement but two
months later held a press conference so
it could apologize to its victims for
the first time in 50 years
foreign
[ __ ] yeah
they never apologized
for the suffering they're caused
and they didn't pay for that you know
for their wrong
there was no apology
apology comes from the heart yeah their
apology came from their lawyers in
our family couldn't have gone into
silent shock we had to get up and face
each day and every day and cope with the
incredible damage the gruenthood
to Lynn and our family
is still a privately owned company the
wurtz family owns it today just as it
did in 1960. it does not have
shareholders demanding
Returns the verts family's personal
Fortune has been variously estimated at
between two and three billion euros
it would not drive that family into
penury or bankruptcy or poverty to
loosen the purse strings and behave in a
more generous fashion towards survivors
I not only want the money I want the
revenge
I want the Revenge you know they they
killed 5 000 children yeah they made
another five thousand children's life
miserable they make the life of ten
thousand parents awful yeah they are
responsible
and they should pay for it
grunenthal no longer makes the line and
continues to deny most thalidomite is
outside Germany any compensation no
survivors feel they have received an
acceptable apology
grenenthal refused to be interviewed for
this film
[Music]
today Celgene continues to prosper from
the sale of its thalidomide-derived
drugs to treat multiple myeloma
prior to getting approval to bring its
version of the drug back onto the market
in 1998 the American Drug Company was
valued at a hundred million dollars
today celgene's value has soared to a
hundred billion dollars
the original thalidomide drug is easy
and cheap to manufacture and continues
to be made and distributed by several
drug companies and governments to treat
leprosy unfortunately it is mostly used
in countries that often do not enforce
rigorous controls and regulations as a
result thalidomide injured babies are
still being born
thalidomide is worldwide buoyed by the
success of the Lynette row case have
renewed efforts to fight for
compensation as they battle with the
continuing side effects
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]